let's throw to just a little bit of
Governor desantis's inauguration speech
this bizarre
massages
purports to act in the name of justice
for the marginalized but it frowns upon
American institutions it rejects Merit
and achievement and it Advocates
identity essentialism
we reject this woke ideology
we seek normalcy not philosophical
lunacy we will not allow reality facts
and Truth to become optional we will
never surrender to the woke mob Florida
is where woke goes to die
so that was the big Applause line of the
whole thing John I want to start with
you since yeah you've you've been here
the longest so you know you helped pave
the road for us crazy refugees normalcy
competency reality I mean nothing he set
up there should be extraordinary and yet
it is and we're all lucky enough to be a
little part of it yeah look I mean
Florida's never really been until Ron
DeSantis a truly conservative State sure
we voted red but uh our state senate has
been pretty Squishy in terms of the
Rhinos I mean there was a Senate
President a while back woman named Ana
Terra Flores from Miami she was a State
Rep she invited moms the man Michael
Bloomberg's gun grabbers in and was
giddy and smiling and taking photos with
them and taking their money but the
Santas grew up in Florida and he watched
the state become purple and creeped
toward blue we almost had Andrew Gillum
as Governor thank God the status one and
DeSantis just literally a meth addict
literally literally a meth addict
literally a meth addict write a lot
about it but the sadness has really
really changed the game in this state
he's gone full bore with conservative
Common Sense policies and we were all
saying this on the plane I think I was
saying this Carol and her husband
what the Santa has done is not complex
you just govern through the lens of the
Constitution of your state and the
Constitution the United States of
America you do what he said you put
Common Sense over this philosophical
nonsense and you wind up with a really
conservative agenda that people love I
mean look we picked up a congressional
seat New York lost one we're doing
something right
Buck I think you're the newest here in
Florida just a couple months in if I'm
not mistaken uh it's working down here
huh
look there's a reason why I think the
number is over 300 000 uh left New York
my home state in in the last year uh and
so not all of them moved to Florida but
a huge portion of them did uh Florida
Texas Tennessee these are all states
where you have more freedom where you
have more sanity in general at the state
government level uh you do have good
cities in all of those States so you
know one of the challenges I think in a
lot of the red States is you go okay
well you know if you if you move to
Montana
you know which isn't even that red as a
state by the way
um but you're not really going to be
able to have a any kind of a city to
live in whereas here we got Miami
obviously Nashville and Tennessee and
then Dallas slash Houston slash well
Austin's a little too commy but I do
love it anyway that's the problem like I
want anarchists covered in tattoos
making my latte because they're really
good at it if you'd like more sane takes
on our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell